اجعل الحروب اصبح اسهل من اشعال سيجاره
الضحايا بمئات الالاف بل لنقل بالملايين
رائحه الدماء تفوح في كل مكان حروب لا احد
يدري لماذا اندلعت وحضارات يتمنى تاريخها
على مرء الجميع حرب العراق واليمن وسوريا
والسودان وافغانستان اذا اردت ان تعرف من
اشعل النار في تلك الدول فلتبحث عن
المستفيد من دفئها اولا نعم هي بمثابه
الشرطه في هذا الكوكب وهي العنوان الابرز
في كل تلك الحروب ولكن الامس ليس كما
اليوم وقبل ان نتحدث في الحاضر دعونا نغوص
في احشاء الماضي الحرب العراقيه امريكا
حاضره الحرب السوريه امريكا حاضره حرب
اليمن والسعوديه هي ايضا حاضره اذا ماذا
استفاد ابناء العم سام من تلك الحروب حرب
العراق وثمارها لو كنت ادرك ذلك لنا شاركت
في العراق هكذا قالها جندي امريكي يدعى
جيش استبر شارك ضمن قوات بلاده في احتلال
العراق فماذا اخذت امريكا من جيوب
العراقيين ولماذا قال تلك الكلمات مهلا
مهلا مهلا فلتقل ماذا تركت القوات
الامريكيه في العراق ولم تاخذ لنبدا
بالقصور الرئاسيه بالعراق لقد اخذت كل ما
تحتويه تلك القصور من كنوز وتحف لا تقدر
بثمن ولا ننسى مغاره علي بابا نعم فقد بدا
الامر كما لو ان جنود الولايات المتحده قد
عثروا على مغاره علي بابا فانتشر ببريق
الذهب الاصفر والتقطوا صورا تذكاريه مع
اقداس السبائك البراقه التي يقدر عددها
بالفينسبيكه كل سبيكه لا تقل عن خمسه كيلو
جرامات نعم لقد اخذوا الحاضر ولم يتركوا
الماضي ايضا ونقصد الاثار العراقيه حيث تم
نهب قطع اثريه يعود عمرها لاكثر من سبعه
الاف سنه فقد اخذ الجيش الامريكي ما يزيد
عن اربعه الاف قطعه اثريه نادره من
المتاحف العراقيه وقام بتهريبها الى
الولايات المتحده مسجلا بذلك اكبر جريمه
سرقه تحدث لمتحف في التاريخ ومن التاريخ
تاخذون اقدامنا الى ثروه الحاضر نعم نقصد
حقول النفط العراقي في ذلك الوقت كان
العراق يمتلك اكبر احتياطي من النفط بعد
السعوديه حيث كان يصل الى ما يقرب من 200
مليار برميل اي ما يعادل 15% من كل
الاحتياطات العالميه وان لم تستحي تصنع ما
شئت استولت الولايات المتحده على النفط
العراقي وتاجرت به وحققت اكثر من 115
مليار دولار بعد مرور عام واحد فقط على
احتلالها العراق اما الجندي الامريكي فقد
اوضح سبب تغير موقفه من حرب بلاده على
العراق قائلا كنت اعتقد اننا ذهبنا للعراق
من اجل اعطاء الشعب العراقي صوتا وفضح
الكذبه الامريكيه التي ادعت ان هدفها من
الغزوه وحمايه الشعب العراقي قائلا تلقى
فريقي امرا بالدخول الى احد الاحياء جنوب
مدينه الصدر وعند وصولنا فرج التظاهره
سلميه لعراقيين يعارضون وجودنا هناك لكننا
تجاهلناهم ودخلنا المنطقه بالقوه نحن لم
نستمع لهم يبدو ان العراق
كان يمثل كنزا تمينا بامريكا فكذبه النووي
اصبحت نكته او اضحوكه سياسيه لقد صرخ هذا
الجندي في وجه بوش لقد كذبتم علينا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
عليها اكثر من مليون ونصف مليون عراقي
راحوا ضحايا ليكون دمهم حبرا على عقد تلك
الصفقه السوداء والتي اجتمعت فيها امريكا
وبريطانيا وبولندا واسبانيا واوكرانيا ولم
تكن الحرب العراقيه الحرب العربيه الوحيده
التي استفادت منها امريكا فكيف استفادت
واشنطن من الحروب الاخرى في المنطقه
العربيه
باب السوري الاسود
مسيره الحرب الامريكيه والاطمار لم تنتهي
في العراق ليكبر طموحها وتتوسع معدتها
لتبتلع اليوم النفط السوري نعم هو المطمع
الرئيسي لاياد الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ومن اجله اشعلت امريكا نهر الفوضى التي لا
تريدها ان تنطفئ اشتعلت المظاهرات في
سوريا وكان الهدف منها تحسين اوضاع الشعب
السوري الطرف الاخر اعتبرها مؤامره خارجيه
لتشتعل البلاد بين الطرفين امريكا تؤيد
المتظاهرين وفي الطرف الاخر قوات النظام
والسلاح يتدفق لسوريا من جميع الاتجاهات
لتشتغل البلاد باكملها ولا ننسى في الطرف
الاخر روسيا التي دعمت قوات النظام عسكريا
لتصبح سوريا ساحه للحرب بين العدوين
اللدودين هنا اليد الخفيه لام تدخل ورقه
داعش ليطفئ النار بالبنزين لقد وجدوا
سلاحا امريكيا ومعدات طبيه امريكيه في
اوكر داعش فمن اين اتت وما مصدرها نترك
الاجابه لكم لتدخل امريكا بقواتها تحت عذر
قتال داعش فالحرب تريد موارد ماليه لتدار
اذا هيا لنضع قواعدنا العسكريه في تلك
الابار النفطيه تم تحرير سوريا من داعش
وسيطرت قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه وحليفتها
الولايات المتحده على معظم مواقع استخراج
النفط والتي وضعت الولايات المتحده يدها
عليها واصبحت اكبر حقول النفط السوري تحت
الحمايه الامريكيه والتي اعلنت ان
البنتاغون على استعداد لحمايه حقول النفط
السوري من اي خطر مهما كان تماما حتى ان
عضو مجلس الدوم الروسي سرجي
لا تخفي الولايات المتحده اهداف السيطره
على حقول النفط السوريه ومن الواضح انها
ستكون مستعده للدفاع عن نواياها باي شكل
من الاشكال
حرب السعوديه واليمن لا ترغب الولايات
المتحده لحرب السعوديه ضد الحوثيين باليمن
ان تهدا فمنذ بدء تلك الحرب تنفق السعوديه
نحو سته مليارات دولار شهريا على دعم
الجيش ومعظم هذه الاموال تذهب الى الخزانه
الامريكيه مقابل شراء السلاح الامريكي
وربما اشعلت امريكا الحروب في مناطق
مختلفه من العالم من اجل بيع السلاح
وانعاش الاقتصاد الامريكي بمليارات
الدولارات كما انها تتصيد الاخطاء بين
الدول المتحاربه حيث يتم حصد عمليات
الجرائم الحرب التي ينفذها اي طرف مثل قتل
المدنيين وغيرها والتي تعتبر جرائم حرب
لتجعل منها ورقه ضغط على هذه الدوله او
تلك فاما ان تتبع سياسه تخدم المصالح
الامريكيه واما ان تستخدم امريكا ذلك
الملف الذي يحت جميع الجرائم الدوليه
ليصبح ملف ابتزاز دولي الهدف منه تحشيد
المجتمع الدولي ضدها لتمطر عليها العقوبات
من كل جانب ومن العقوبات الاقتصاديه
الخانقه وبشان قله الاكسجين والاختناق
الدولي حققت امريكا هدفا عميقا من حرب
اليمن والسعوديه وهو السيطره على شريان
مضيق باب المندب الاستراتيجي حيث زعمت
الاداره الامريكيه ان الوجود العسكريه لها
في باب المندب يهدف الى حمايه المضيق من
الاعتداءات لاكثر ولكن يبدو ان الامر اعمق
من ذلك بكثير كما اخبرتكم وكما يقول
الخبراء من يسيطر على مضيق باب المندب
يسيطر على اوروبا باكملها فمعظم امدادات
الطاقه لاوروبا تمر عبر هذا المضيق حيث
يربط باب المندب بين البحر الاحمر وخليج
عدن وبحر العرب ويعتبر بوابه الرئيسيه
لاوروبا من جهه الخليج العربي ويمر عبره
اكثر من اربعه ملايين برميل من النفط
يوميا فان اغلاق باب المندب يعني تجمد دول
اوروبا كلها ولا ننسى ان مضيق باب المندب
يمثل 15% من التجاره العالميه فاين تذهب
كل تلك الايرادات لنعد الى عصر عاشور
الناجي نعم فامريكا تاخذ الاتاوات تحت بند
الحمايه ان كنت تريد الحمايه لتمر من هذا
المضيق يجب ان تدفع ورقه العداء السعودي
الايراني كانت الولايات المتحده المستفيده
الاكبر من الغداء السعودي الايراني الذي
دام لاكثر من اربعين عاما فالخطر الايراني
على السعوديه كانت تهديد الاكبر الذي
انعشت به امريكا خزانته بمليارات
الدولارات التي كانت تدفعها السعوديه
حمايتها العسكريه كما كانت السعوديه تشكل
خطرا على ايران حيث كانت السعوديه ورقه
ضغط امريكيه على ايران في قضيه ملفها
النوويه وكانت ايران تخشى استخدام امريكا
للحدود السعوديه لضربها عسكريا معتمده في
ذلك على العداء الشديد بين البلدين ولكن
هدت الرياح بما لا تشتهي امريكا فقبل فتره
وجيزه اعلنت السعوديه وايران انهما قد
توصلت لاتفاق صلح بينهما ببساطه صينيه
وبالطبع دخول التنين الصيني في المعادله
يعني وجود الدب الروسي ايضا فيها بشكل او
باخر لتحريم الصين وروسيا الولايات
المتحده من اهم ركائزها في التحكم بمنطقه
الشرق الاوسط والخليج العربي ولا ننسى سعي
روسيا للاصلاح بين بشار الاسد واردوغان
هنا سيطول الحديث فاذا اردت م سيكون لنا
فيديو قادم حول خطه روسيا والصين التي
تهدف الى قطع الموارد الامريكيه من الدول
العربيه سجل اعجابك واشترك في القناه
ليصلك الجديد
[موسيقى]